iron rusts from disuse
water loses its purity from stagnation
even so does an action sap the vigor of
the mind
time stays long enough
for anyone who will use it
poor is the pupil who does not surpass
his master
there are three classes of people
those who see
those who see when they are shown
those who do not see
i am not poor poor are those who desire
many things
our life is made by the death of others
wisdom is the daughter of experience
[Music]
reprove your friend in secret
and praise him in public
god sells us all things at the price of
labor
as a well-spent day brings happy sleep
so a life well spent
brings happy death
[Music]
patience serves as a protection against
wrongs
as clothes do against cold
learning never exhausts the mind
tears come from the heart
and not from the brain
[Music]
while i thought that i was learning how
to live
i have been learning how to die
the greatest deception men suffer
is from their own opinions
he who walks straight rarely falls
just as food eaten without appetite is a
tedious nourishment
so does study without zeal damage the
memory
by not assimilating what it absorbs
marriage is like putting your hand into
a bag of snakes in the hope of pulling
out an eel
he who can copy can do
[Music]
he who wishes to be rich in a day
will be hanged in a year
just as courage imperils life
fear protects it
he who thinks little airs much
all knowledge which ends in words will
die as quickly as it came to life
with the exception of the written word
which is its mechanical part
he who does not punish evil
commands it to be done
it is an acknowledged fact that we
perceive errors in the work of others
more readily than in our own
no counsel is more trustworthy than that
which is given upon ships that are in
peril
he who does not value life does not
deserve it
beauty perishes in life
but is immortal in art
he who possesses most must be most
afraid of loss
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe